In 1913, Hitler, Stalin, Trotsky, Tito and
Freud, all lived within a few miles of each
other in Vienna, with some of them being regulars
at the same coffeehouses.
The penalty for adultery in ancient Greece
involved hammering a radish into the adulterer's
bottom with a mallet.
Radishes were a lot longer and pointier in
those days.
By the age of 18, the average American child
will have seen 200,000 murders on television.
In 1672 an angry mob of Dutchmen killed and
ate their prime minister.
McDonald's is one of the largest owners of
real estate in the world and it earns the
majority of its profits from collecting rent,
not from selling food.
Inuits use refrigerators to stop their food
from freezing.
In 2008, Usain Bolt set the world record for
the 100 metres with one shoelace undone.
J.K.
Rowling, author of the Harry Potter series,
is the first person to become a billionaire
by writing books.
Antarctic islands include Disappointment Island,
Fabulous Island, Desolation Island, Monumental
Island, Inexpressible Island, Shag Island,
Circumcision Island and Shoe Island.
Iceland was once called 'Butterland' because
the grass was so rich it seemed to drip butter.
Since 1700, new beetle species have been discovered
at the rate of one every six hours.
When trying out a new pen, 97% of people write
their own name.
A trained typist's fingers cover about 16
miles a day.
20% of all road accidents in Sweden involve
an elk.
Every US president with a beard has been Republican.
90% of everything written in English uses
just 1,000 words.